hello my name is equal vigor if thank
you for joining me today it's a little
bit unusual for me to give a talk to
virtual world when I don't see the
audience but I hope y'all listening and
if you listen and if you have a question
during the course of my talk you can
click on a button kna an old corner of
your screen and type me a question and
by the end of the talk I hope to address
most of the questions that they will
receive today I would like to talk about
future it will not be connected to human
house but it will be important in
relation to human health it will be
about health of planet if you look at my
first slide you see two options we may
have for the future one on the right
side is bright sunny and clean water and
one on the left side is a little bit
darker and unfortunately we have choice
of either of them in different parts of
the world and these are two options for
our immediate future and they directly
related to energy and environment
challenges that we face in right now I
think I believe strongly that biology
and in particular genomics offers tools
that would help us to better understand
the processes going on in nature and
help us to shift the balance towards
brighter and hopefully happier future
which we see as an example on the right
side so I work for the joint genome
Institute where I lived fond of genomics
program and hopefully by the end of the
stroke
will convince you that fungi play
important role in nature and
understanding genes encoded in the
genome will help us to control our
future so join the law institute let me
start this couple words about during
genome Institute or jgi it's a generic
center located in walnut creek here is
here map the red dot on a map indicates
our location we located long kick not
far away from San Francisco it is in
California but we are also department of
energy genomics user facility probably
the only genomics facility in the world
devoted to the problems of energy and
environment well there are many centers
devoted to human house and this map also
indicates users different groups of
researchers from all the work not only
from the united states that currently
work with us on different genomics
projects and trying to give answer
different types of questions qn genome
institute started back in nineteen
ninety nine with the idea to contribute
to the human genome project which was
very active at that time and really
successfully sequenced finish dinner
date is 15 on chromosomes and since then
our main focus was on missions of
deployment of energy which by energy
carbon cycle and by ikea and
biochemistry the three major areas where
different questions could be dressed
with genomic science as I mentioned we
started with human genome project and
that was hard to put sequencing on
Sunday machines and we live in an era of
genomics revolution where every other
year
have a new sequencing platform which
leads to a lines of genomic data that
need to be interpreted and we try
different platforms you are four by four
Illumina Pacific Biosciences and father
that your name and combination of the
couple of those right now give us
ability to produce a broad spectrum of
product struggling with sequencing and
reference genomes transcriptomes an
Origin expression of genes on different
or fun to growing under different
conditions and not only fungal unit of
course look at population questions we
sequence in the natural variation or
engineered strains and all this huge
amount of data reduced by the sequencers
other than analyzed with various
analytical bad ones that run on
supercomputer are all the various
congressional clusters in supercomputer
center in Berkeley which North is our
partner and the another thing that we do
none which is our strategic goal is to
go from sequence to the function with
this explosion of sequencing techniques
we and different other different centers
produce huge amounts of data we have
tones of sequence but where little is
known still about function and would
like to bridge this gap between the
right number sequences and very small
number of functions by developing heart
we would techniques for functional
genomics transcript starting from
transcriptomics keepsake photonics and
other
in world of fungal genomics the program
that we started about three years ago at
this point we contribute into modern
half of the projects around the world
tangled genomics projects according to
the gold database which is trying to
keep track of various genomics projects
heaven different part of the world all
the sequence data is then processed
genomes assembled annotated and
integrated with various analytical tools
on the portal the best portal quotes
microcosm which is available at this web
address you see on the screen 3g idea
that grow fresh fungi which currently
has over 250 signals to notated fungal
genomes and this number is growing very
fast to make sure that the data we
produce and the tools that we also
deliver are used we focus our efforts on
user support and that varies from
participating and meeting like that and
making sure that this genomic user
facility is available for immigrant the
world to sequence various genomes
basically for free and for sequence
genomes that were proposed we would like
to make sure that the group of people
who worked on the genome effectively use
the tools we recognize workshops and
jamboree to discuss findings coming out
from analysis of sequences and
the value of fungi exhibition in various
different ways here's an example of a
dish that was produced by various fungi
first of all it's mushrooms as you see
on the top then the brand produced by
with how to break a wrist when the
cheese were fungal an important role as
well even the little plan that you see
on the top most probably can't grow
without symbiotic association with
mycorrhizae fungi and what you don't see
the fogger iety of drinks from beer to
wine for fermenting you require from G
as well so from the important is a fruit
on the other side of this picture you
can see this virtually scary images of
different diseases that caused by fungal
pathogens pathogens of human and wells
that create basis for international
stories like x-files to scare people
it's a good father but this is a reality
and the reality of the drives
development of different drums on the
other hand fungi produce drugs starting
from penicillin and well this basically
several examples to illustrate how fungi
important in our day-to-day life but
these are not the reason why deployment
of languages interested in front of
genetics for bradley's energy-related
prospective industry enough vanja are
very important for growing premise and
converting biomass into biofuel on this
slide you see how well a different
stages of that process different types
of fungi plan critical role for example
in order to get a sustainable growth of
plants you need to know everything about
first plant diseases and explore fungal
pathogens as well as understand
symbiotic interactions between plants
and for example Mike Araiza that deliver
various nutrients for plants to grow
once you get once you're capable to
produce sufficient biomass its need to
be converted into sugars and then by
ethanol and fungi are the organisms that
know how to overcome the barriers that
plants develop during the evolution
weakness Elvis that compose plant cell
walls and not only help plants to grow
and protect them from microbial attack
well once you convert luminescent a
single sugar again fungi such as yeast
can follow fermented to ethanol and in
addition to that fungi are very
important hosts in industry they use as
the useless producers of different
enzymes the potential for machinery in
Boyle family which you can think about
it as a factory converting biomass into
biofuel as alternative to oil refinery
that they used currently so another to
understand different aspects of how
fungi operate and their different roles
we need to sequence a genome and fungal
history of JD I started around
time when we finished with a human
genome project back in two thousand for
the first fungus the first lady I found
with the sequence it was the first
basidiomycete Whitewood fungus phonetic
leaders forum it was a big deal and you
see the image of this fungus on a cloud
of nature biotechnology journal and
since then there were many publications
were represented the first of its kind
fungus sales fermenters which I'll touch
on in my talk both pathogens and senior
at poplar tree another type of food
became fungus brown rot thermophilic
fungi that important for industry and at
some point thinking about this
individual story we come up with the
idea that instead of looking at
individual Gina we should look at the
group of organisms that show similar
traits for example look at all syndromes
or pathogens as a group sequence genomes
of diverse representatives of this group
and compare them side-by-side and try to
align the trades of the common between
them with jeans that are shared let's
give a starter project which called
genomic encyclopedia laundry this is
méxico Billy again for energy
environment related questions and
instead of individual publication was
thinking about chapter chapters focused
on plant house chapter focused on by
refinery and chapter focused on fungal
diversity I mentioned the designs user
facility and every year he'll call for
proposals anybody can apply to that and
basically to risk all we can open new
first in this encyclopedia but right now
for the rest of my dog this will surface
on flying I will talk a little bit about
different phone jailbroken plant health
related questions then a little bit /
refineries and fungal diversity let's
start with the first question several
years ago we published signals and
publish the genome of the first three
poplar and also start looking at
microbes and fungi associated with this
tree so that we build both sort of
minimal ecosystems so single a chemical
or associated mycorrhizal fungus
associated with the roots of cobbler and
pathogen of corporal leaves besides
interaction of fungi with its host with
this plan cost we also going to explore
questions of different lifestyles that
we observed in the kingdom of fungi
symbiosis butter Genesis and support
rafi ability to live on a dead matter
and see what is common within each of
these groups and what is different
between all three of these groups
struggle is one of the examples
packaging of Papua norms roller is
obscene it's also called proper rust
it's projects we Wharton together with a
broad institute who explored another
rust We Trust and signals in the genome
produced significant of both genomes
reduced really large assembly if the
average side of fungal genome assemblies
worth 40 mega bases so these two fungi
us first 100 mega bases there are four
transporters well approximately half of
the journals were transported all
elements these are obligate parasites
they can live only in
and the planned in fact and reason for
that based on an ounce of genome was
broken metabolism lack of seven genes
that required for the core metabolism
but the most interesting finding was a
huge expansion in the number of genes
coding small secreted proteins which we
think are critical in communication with
a plant host in controlling plan costs
and all the this is the very same
proteins and distribution of these
proteins are shown in this diagram so
those it in rant where the most
expressed proteins when we looked at
transcriptomics expression of genes
during leaf inflection so the slow
secreted proteins are very important for
pathogens in comparison we can add the
sort of opposites lifestyle symbiosis we
can think about extra micro rises to the
fungus that entered very close
interactions with plant roots so you see
little flames its root system and this
dance patches of association between
plant roots and fungal mycelium and
again a lot of signaling is involved so
the first to make a reso fun with lock
arabic o war was sequenced it was also
relatively large the large number of
different genes and over 500 small
secreted protein the most of expressed
gene in this genome world's small
secreted protein that was called knit
sell it shown over 20,000 fault or
expression in the microgravity shoe
commercial 23 million fungus and for the
analysis of this little protein
indicated that with gene is mostly
expressed as you
image on the right which in green shows
expression of this gene and it's
expressed in a space between the plant
root cells indicating that it's
expressed right there during association
of Trumbull spheres the plant and this
is a very intimate interaction and
network of fungus called karthik network
basically it's word processing to
interface between fungus implant so this
is one side of human called signaling
and close interaction with its host on
the other hand it's still the composer
it's able it's capable of decomposing
dead material dead organic matter and
for that we explored enzymes involved in
this process called carbohydrate active
enzymes or designs for grated and we're
surprised that in comparison to other
fungi of different lifestyles but licari
bacolod has the slowest number of genes
almost no genes involved in the
composition of clients elbow so the
first time leah was that probably
evolutionary this organism eliminated
all the genes that could potentially
trigger plant responds because planned
trying to defend themselves from
invasion from pathogens and whatever
thorough may try to eliminate all of
them so in order to better understand
this let's let's look close a different
type of franchise suburbs and in
particular would became fungi i
mentioned that limo service is a
material that built trans ovals it's
composed of cell walls which is this
chain of lupus
it's which are then wrapped and
connected with each other by moguls of
Hannah solos and wrapped in linen and
all this is protecting service from
Mikado attack I also mentioned that
funds among those organs who know how to
overcome this barrier and the very first
fungus that I already mentioned for
Nikita chrysosporium because white short
decay which he see on this little image
its genome includes genes that are
critical for the composition of both
sewers and lignin and Hannah syllables
and we found broadcast elephant science
involved in the gradation of all this
biopolymers fears letter later are we
sequenced another woulda came from Jay
was the placenta which is a different
type of floater to measure type of food
decay once called white wrote that
caused liberation of all three
components lignin souls in heaven
service brown rot is capable to degrade
service and hannah service but not
lignin and that's what we've seen of the
sequence in the genome no enzymes
involved in lignin degradation to our
biggest surprise we all sit in find the
enzymes that were involved in the
gradation of service none of the genes
we found in warren short were found in
brownwood that are responsible for this
process but instead in combination with
transcriptomics and proteomics data we
found in direct evidence of maybe an
alternative mechanism called phantom
chemistry which produce hyperactive
hydroxyl radicals so this is a normal
somatic way to attack molecules of souls
and
decompose it too degraded to small units
and ultimately after Lucas so that was
two points of data sampling two genomes
of weekend from jail and two completely
different mechanisms or encoding image
of this genome that he was ground to
start sequencing whoa that's what we did
and last year we did a study published a
study of incorporation was still he good
from Clark University and his colleagues
where we compared side-by-side not to
but 12 different we became function and
they're shown on this diagram Brown rod
foreground forward in brown with handles
for ground rod from giant white
rectangles for white respond J so this
much large amount of data allowed us to
look different genes and different
processes a little bit closer and what's
more importantly in evolutionary context
having always holding on data we could
reconstruct so genetic relationships and
we construct relational paths and we can
from I agree that was expressed earlier
that probably both types of food decay
emerge from white roads ancestor again
this data using techniques called
molecular clock analysis we were not
only able to reconstruct the ancestor
and also look at approximately at the
time when it's emerged when it's evolved
and estimated that that's happened
probably around three hundred million
years ago interestingly enough around
the race same time according to
geological records the amount of organic
material converted to call some
marriages so if we don't think about
your history in terms of millions of
years here
you probably remember that between 400
million years ago and 300 million years
ago the plaid dress was covered with
prehistoric forest trees were living
growing dying and ultimately converted
into call Libyan is a precursor for the
call and probably the very first wide
Road fungus figure out ways how to enter
matically process ligon and basically
could be potentially a reason that will
lead us in some future to call crisis
but at the same time the very same fungi
keep secrets that could be used by us in
order to understand how to process
biomass and produce fulfill for our
needs with an identical approaches so
that was little story about food decay
and let's go back to single runs
interestingly enough you always see on
all these trees I'll go to really sweat
you'll always see on this tree is lock
area as a member of this agric America
team that is google fungi and we looked
at enzymatic profile the number of
enzymes is smaller than others but we
also see reductions similar to ground
watts there are evidence that brown rot
fungi which can destroy our homes can
also grow and wrap the root system of
different friends in a way similar to
acting like a rise of symbiotic fungi
and under the microscope we can also see
that fungal cells we are going to very
intimate interactions with a plant root
cells but they not form in the network
as we see in four symbols
I interested in laughlin for a genetic
tree very often we see wrong words next
to ectomycorrhizal enjoy those a Martin
Brown and oranges and we're open their
sister groups meaning that they have a
say they come we were from same ancestor
and probably some sweets and was a gain
of some group of genes let these
different types of wives that they leave
and flood analysis more recent data
indicating metabolomics analysis
analysis of small components and
molecules they produce also suggest that
maybe add to micro riser subtle back to
my garage of genomes include genes that
may be conducting the very same kind of
chemistry that brown roads are doing so
that's very interesting and suggests
sampling symbiotic fungi at much larger
scale and this is exactly what we are
doing one of the projects initiated by
elaborated frances martin from england
france he with a large group of
researchers around the world is looking
at sequence win 30 Michael Riedel gina's
and on this picture we see illustration
on a petri dish scale illustration of
what's happened in nature interestingly
got eighty percent of plants for micro
Rifle Association and many of them
cannot live without such association the
reason for that is my coryza is capable
to transfer nutrients to plants such as
phosphorus and without which ones can
regrow what's interesting when these
pictures amount of green material
similar early stages where the amount of
green materials much smaller than what
you see on the
equivalent of what you see Angeles on
the surface in Xena soil and let's
reflect the situation in nature it's
known that forest sink for carbon if we
think about carbon cycles but recent
study indicate that the world of that
carbon goes into roots and the fungal
material associated his route so at this
point we have about 20 genome sequenced
they represent different types of my
karate association we're talking about a
chemical or actor Michael Rifle
Association which is in the middle where
fungal material grows in between two
hundred cells which are these blue
rectangles and this another maybe more
broadly another type of fun on my great
association called our whistle were fun
jabbed role in to plant cells and other
types called airport and orchids where
combination of balls can be found on
phylogenetic site there are organisms
that are known to be Mike Rizzo at
happening different groups of fungi
suggesting that this life style evolved
many times in the history of fungi and
so that's hopefully right now how about
20 genomes their comparative analysis
indicated with the diversity of gene
sets that may correlate with different
lifestyles I mentioned small secreted
proteins for Korea the second sequenced
to make our mycorrhizal fungus truffle
actually drawn by the same love for
frances martin indicators there are no
specific proteins its organs belonging
to completely different
group and this whole spectrum of jeans
and codes and 20 genomes and a fall
until these groups those that interact
his plans biologically proteins and
other jobs where to summarize this part
of my talk I would like to again
Hawaiian that well if you look at what
what we tried to do is to look at
individual groups of pathogens human
suburbs find features shared between
them and to our surprise there is no
diversity within the group than
similarity between the groups we talked
about very different ways of the
gradient woods included in genomes of
brown and white rod we talked about
similarities between mike rizzo symbols
and pathogens and there are organizing
data of white wrote in one hand and
packaging of different trees on another
so it's hard to draw clear ones between
them but I hope hopefully I Illustrated
how genomics can you some ideas of
what's going on and with different types
of fungi but the next step in this
process is functional drugs to
understand what each of these genes to
and how they interact with each other
and how they're regulated within each of
these genomes with that we're going to
the next more applied chapter of this
encyclopedia called by refinery but the
goal of this project is to it's a little
bit more pragmatic a little bit more
quiet we would like to come up with a
collection of genes that could be used
by industry with collection of pathways
include it in the sequence genomes and
with a collection of costs or at least
explore the force that are currently
used for different purposes and think
about it as a list of parts
part of barbed wire parts from which by
refinery or other application machinery
can be constructed I mentioned that
that's why we're doing this large-scale
sequencing large-scale sequencing of
would be gained from j us largest most
comprehensive collecting or food Akane
enzymes and the only thing we have at
this point is predicted function for
many of them in order to understand what
they do we need to develop a model
currently there is a couple of
well-established models in from the
world so her my sister is here east and
north across the floor Memphis fungus
but they all belong to the group of
Oscar Isaacs we do not have would be gay
and fungi which have different type of
micro sim biotic interactions with plans
and in order to understand Vasudha my
system processes in college there would
like to pick one of the organ here and
one of those models is a genome that we
all sickness at JDI the genome is a
feelin comin wit is a model mushroom
which is organ it is used to understand
how mushroom is formed the way to do it
is to take a wild type strain glue some
mutations knockout transcription factors
for example and see how you can grow
with mutagenized from this only to
certain stage that for example it cannot
grow fully developed mushrooms and by
combination of this experiment of
different accounts you can begin to
identify all key transcription factors
that regulate the processes of national
development you can take those mutants
and run transcriptomics analysis and see
how that's a
Gene's downstream that's regulated by
those transcription factors and from
that model the Cascade of interactions
between different transcription factors
and other genes so going through a
process of sequencing i can define
function of individual genes or groups
of genes and then modeling the process
is encoded by those jeans right now this
is this probably the only one of the few
basidiomycete it can be transformed and
where those mutations can be done and we
currently growing this and JJ I to
understand how is fungus gross and
different this is a white rot fungus
House bills and different types of four
different carbon sources on liberal
syllables different types of food and
using similar approaches try to
understand which transcription factors
are critical to switch from one type of
food to another 40 for this fungus and
ultimately well glute genes / express
genes from other organism and see what
combination of what cocktails of enzymes
and more efficient for different types
of food and how they are regulated so
that was an example of host remodel
reusing and talking about pathways
beyond individual genes I would like to
mention experiment the collaboration
with great leg by science by energy
center where we looked at the next step
after the composition of lignocellulose
converging sugar into ethanol so
pharmacist servicio make your list can
easily convert glucose into ethanol and
at the same time probably about the
quarter of primal friend biomass is
composed of silos different types of
sugar which is uniquely processed by
fungi
I inhabiting grad stuff beetles that
live from different clans food chemicals
the fungi that grow in absence of oxygen
and sequencing of that type of fungi
first of which will be the stupidest we
identified and we're able to reconstruct
the pathway that leads not only from
glucose to ethanol but from silos to
ethanol I mean five genes at a critical
for that that allows other people to try
to integrate those genes into organism
into genomics Sarah my sister Alicia to
make me that organism can work not only
glue blows but Silas work all sugars
that only one measure sugar that we can
obtain from plant material so next that
happened and performance so that
modifying supremacist arisia wasn't the
best that triggered the next step of
development and looking closely and the
group's group groups of organ that can
consume Silas and convert it into
ethanol they are marked here in blue we
have thrilled them and compare them and
contrast with rosetta purple which can
consume silos but do not produce ethanol
and with all other articles so we have
many tools for these types of conversion
so we can look at their genomes and see
what's common between blue jeans and
purple gems we can look at chaska clones
and see what is the most expressed genes
in one group versus another and combine
all this potential candidates for
further improvement of saccharomyces
cerevisiae production strain we come up
with a subset of g
and our collaborators with great legs
when the center are working on
integrating them disagreements a series
and showing that improved versions have
improved service utilization better
growth and ultimately better production
of ethanol so this is an example where
you can go from genome sequence and to
compare different analysis
transcriptomics and other experimental
techniques identifying genes that could
help you to adjust industrial separates
organism to do something else something
that you wanted to do and been able not
only to model but to to really create
modified organism with desired property
that probably concludes the port to
illustrate I'll approach to 24 by parts
for which we can impose different type
of machinery including by our finest and
i'm going to say couple words about the
final chapter which is focused on
diversity do i estimate it over a
million and a half of different species
of fungi and explained very little is
known about them very few local tourists
and there is almost no genomic
information conversing to bacteria and
other organisms on this picture you see
some of examples i'm growing in nature
many of them can not be cultured and on
the other hand you see measure groups of
fungi that colorless million-plus
different species and how they
evolutionary way to each other the goal
of this chapter is to understand both
ecological
Oh genetic diversity of function if we
think about wood DK I just mentioned how
we study individual organisms to see
what genes encode look there that enable
this would be k how we can use model
August to validate some of these
functions if you think about nature how
would the K happens in nature's probably
through a succession of different
organisms one doing some function
another little comments after that and
maybe together with other groups of
organs from j-ville prokaryotes became
certain elements of leaf litter and
would mature so instead alternative
approach instead of looking at function
of individual genes and instead of
working on individual genomes we can
look at into our community and this
direction is called metagenomics and
with the Giants for eukaryotic organism
is a little bit more challenging so it's
running full speed for bacteria where
each gene is an open reading frame and
it's a little bit easier to predict
jeans on sequence bacterial or kyojin on
in eukaryotic organism which gene is a
combination of exons and introns that
are spliced out an example for the
transcript and then translated predict
on those exams one structure is
virtually challenging in eukaryotes and
signals that determined that boundaries
of genes boundaries of exams varies from
mortgage to organs the data produced by
metagenomics or relatively complex
community we talkin about work your
short reads for use by email for example
the 150 base pairs long they can be
assembled by if the community is complex
where the scientists of the finance with
the sandwich from this visceral to a
small and often not sufficient even to
predict a single coverage
so therefore in order to do metagenomics
records you need a lot of reference
genomes with genomes is which you can
compare your fragments the assembled
fragments and determine who we chose
this organs a close relative of those
reference organism is present in your
community and one of the projects that
we have again collaborating with Francis
markland from an MC from France is to
look at several forest sites look at
diversity or from the image of them and
not only identify composition of fungal
going those forests but maybe try to
isolate a girl some representatives and
basically metagenomics is composition of
different approaches at this point first
is a profiling determining what type of
species growing in your community and
for fungi the marker is news is called
IDs in Toronto skype sequence basically
design parameters you use it for organ
appeal can a mature that we get and you
identify the adversity of different
species you'll find that metagenomics I
I mentioned this challenging and we need
a lot of reference genome and you can
produce reference you know for the
community that you investigated by
growing in isolates or we can look at
meta transcriptomics where we overcome
the issue of predicting complex gene
structure and looking at the transcripts
so ready spliced and Victorian to open
reading frame and look not only at
composition of species right but
functions genes of the mostly expressed
functional dynamics of those function
within a community but here again
ideally you have a reference set of
genomes and we can produce these
references within context of individual
projects but you can also generate the
general framework
where and that's lead to my next topic
the project called 1000 from the genome
project led by joy Spadafora from our
Oregon State University which is a
collaboration of 15 different labs and
culture collection which idea to produce
in about five years sequences of about
1,000 genomes and it's not the number
that is important here so the goal is to
cover the whole diversity of fungi that
exist in nature and as organizing
principle we're looking at the level
whole families there are classes orders
file and where families of fundraiser is
about five to six hundred different
families and for small fraction of those
we have this single gene out of to be
used as a reference cuz I need to
produce reference genomes for one a
couple of genomes for each of these five
to six hundred families and all this
Lucy tree showing different cuates and
within every class you see the bra
reflecting diversity so for example you
have about hundred families in the city
of icicle avaricum myself there are
classes that are not as diverse but
still very little known about them winco
indicate families with no jeans blue
indicate groups where we have genetic
information and relatives that in
progress so you see that majorities
green we need to sequence that and while
working with culture collections we open
this project for entire condo community
of community of fungal biologists
everybody around the world can go to all
side microcosm side clean button nine
eight and nine eight species for
sequencing and those green area for the
families where there is no sequence
information you can suggest sequence
some species for which you can provide
DNA RNA material so hopefully through
this effort we can build a much more
comprehensive reference data set forth
automatic genomic studies for by the
systematics for phylogenetic studies and
other applications and since I mentioned
one of the function of microcosm side i
would like to also illustrate some tools
that involved in analysis through this
side which is once again available to
anybody at JJ you go / fungi which
currently have a collection of 250
fungal genomes you can click on any
nodes of this tree which one handle
straight from the mycelium hopefully or
another illustrate for genetic
relationships between different groups
of fungi and read the groups of fungal
for which you have some sequence genomes
in grey those that remain to be export
is they are not public yet or not
published emails you can click on this
each of the smells and ask questions
related to small groups or travel
through the tree and ask questions
relate it to hold on Jeff for example
find genes amano 250 fungi using the
keyword search blast analysis or
download those sequences so I mentioned
function of nomination you can add to
this tree we get in there an example
with sequins on our table and they will
be added to this collection of 250 and
then you can explore those genomes in
two principal ways either through
general centric analysis focusing on
that particular organism or through
comparative analysis for the nodes where
you have more than one you know we can
compare them side-by-side the heart of
Jong centric analysis is genome browser
which displays
genome sequence scaffolds and projects
of assembled trees along horizontal axis
and different features found to predict
it being those scaffolds the context for
example the first check on this screen
is his GC count normal DNC as that
illustrate new role composition and get
that composition of that organism so in
the rent Yoo si Jin model track where we
see all the predicted models predicted
by different algorithms sometimes we're
from one genome to another we're trying
to find optimal solution for each of
them in green you see expressed sequence
taxius kids transcriptomic state map to
very same assembly and in purple regions
of phrenology similarity on a protein
level between genes cognitive and Reese
genomes and genes from other organs this
browser is interactive you can zoom in
zoom out to move to the next cattle we
move to the next part of this particular
scaffold each of these tracks is
connected to these external tools or to
the tool that allows you to explore
function of individual genes in detail
so here's a gene report where you see
identify all the gene predicted function
the transcript composed of exons and
introns translated into protein sequence
in green for which repeat domains here
in orange for which we identify also
come along by running brass or other
types of sequence alignment and all
these labels and images are interactive
and allow you to get more information
one of the important features of JD I
browser the giant in on centric analysis
for every genome that is sequence around
eight we also
for tools for manual curation community
formed around each of these genomes or
brutal genomes can go to a website from
their offices and added some of the
function add functional information and
data will find the structure of
predicted genes and principal
investigator of each project usually
coordinate activity with this group and
well we welcome a new members of the
group so if you interested in particular
pathway you can contact us contact bi
and join the effort norm area and
exploration of these genomes require
significant efforts and a lot of many
observation in so here's example teams
curated by one of our greatest cosine
function and some notes all right in
addition to that there is convert set of
comparative tools that allows you to
align genomes one against another here
he visto and alignment translated GMA
whole genome rallied en el limon
translated into dope wat which indicates
regions of flow cold medicine journey
where you see with God CC genes that are
shared between two organism and the
order for genes same between chromosomes
in different organ but not necessary in
some gana quarter bottom you see a
sample of the clustered gene family
where all the members of the cluster can
be compared side by side the gene
structures at the main composition where
local symphony or function of the gene
that surrounded which cluster can do
been translated click you treat
wide-scale statistic number of genes in
particular families can be converted
side by side and we functionality genes
according to grow keg & Co
classifications to summarize what I
mentioned in within a photo program
we asked various scientific questions we
interested in interactions and between
from Jersey charland plants and
evolution we interested in more applied
words developing a body parts list for
buildings and machinery by refinery we
want to explore complexity of IP system
and diversity of fungi where user
facilities therefore will welcome
proposals from different research groups
and to give organizational principle to
different types of proposals we have
this project of generic encyclopedia
where we can other groups of on J 1004
which you can nominate genome sequencing
to organizing new charter recent square
P there we'd have a project 1000 genome
where you can eliminate miss pitches for
sequencing and send us samples basically
all year round and we started efforts of
functional genomics and we encourage
corporations with different groups all
the sequenced genomes we have developed
tools for writing proposals submitting
them sequencing assembly are taken in
genomic data and exploring game as well
supporting this exploration using
web-based tools these different
opportunities which you can interact
with jgi football something to sequence
develop new technologies or just simply
visit us and I also like to mention the
medium that happens next March one of
the largest genomics meeting to order to
energy and environment in March it into
plenty here and won't speak when you can
see the facilities and here interesting
stories that coming from genomic
exploration so this point I would like
to conclude my talk and acknowledge jji
stuff all our users and once again refer
to the tools that we have and if you
have any questions feel free to submit
them now I don't see anything yet but if
you have
maybe not right away but way to these
slides will be available in my email is
in front page with slide back thank you
very much for time hopefully I will
slightly different perspective from
fungi on problems of energy environment
in how we can help to solve them with
genomics tools thanks